moi j'ai créé ma boulangerie dans le
centre de Paris après 15 ans de rêve
évidemment avec un bel endroit mais un
gros loyer
du personnel parce que je fabrique tout
et le côté atypique de ma maison c'est
que je suis seul à avoir créé cette
maison j'ai pas de Marie boulanger pas
d'associé ni de financier donc je suis
arrivé avec mes petits mes petites mes
petites économies j'ai tout investi je
suis une passionnée je suis tellement
heureuse de satisfaire mes clients donc
tout va bien je travaille 17h par jour
bon ça c'est un peu normal si je jure
sur 7 11 mois et demi par an il y a pas
de souci je paye mes charges tout va
bien vous restez un petit peu un petit
quelque chose avant ou pas moi c'est un
petit quelque chose pour vivre vraiment
vous voilà avant avant tout ce qui se
passe maintenant c'est plutôt bien non
non parce que quand on a pas de Marie
boulanger qu'on n'est pas deux à avoir
quatre mains chacun qu'on est seul on a
besoin de plus de personnes donc plus de
personnels plus de charges bon mais
vous en sortir je m'en sors je
capitalise je me disais même si t'as pas
les moyens de toute façon comme l'a dit
ton père tu m'auras pas de faim parce
que je me nourris sur mon entreprise
premièrement donc ça c'est plutôt pas
mal et puis je me disais ben j'ai du
capitalisme donc un jour je récupérerai
l'argent de cette boutique et puis je
pourrais préparer ma retraite bon dire
faire autre chose enfin voilà
je continue bien sûr en 2018 ça a
commencé par les gilets jaunes qui
passaient devant ma boutique tous les
samedis bon bah pas de chance je
comprends les gens se descendent en 2019
les grèves moi je suis au Halles donc
les halles 750 000 personnes que le
trafic distribue
la plus de plus de plus de clients plus
de
plus de plus de personnes 2019 donc
voilà 2020 le covid arrive rue Turbigo
puis le bureau
tous nos bobos partis dans leur maison
de retraite plus de plus de clients donc
obligé de fermer la boutique et puis là
on vous donne 2500 euros par mois pour
vous aider super donc bah écoutez on
retrousse les manches on vit de
l'angoisse on vit du stress mais c'est
pas grave on y va on aime ce qu'on fait
moi mes clients m'adorent donc c'est
parfait aujourd'hui la facture
d'électricité vous payez que vous avez
payé combien avant alors déjà les
factures d'électricité vraiment je pense
qu'il faut avoir de fait de très hautes
études pour comprendre ces factures
d'électricité
je m'y suis penchée mais je m'arrache
les cheveux j'ai juste fait le rapport
entre l'année dernière et cette année au
31 décembre voilà l'année dernière en
2021 j'ai payé 10000 386 euros
d'électricité très bien moi je vais pas
une grosse boulangerie je sors pas 1500
baguettes 2000 baguettes par jour parce
que là je suis à 150 baguettes par jour
donc ça veut dire que je rallume mes
fours l'après-midi quand même jusqu'à
20h pour offrir à ma clientèle des
baguettes chaudes voilà
cette année au 31 décembre j'ai donné
chez EDF à EDF 21 euros
985 donc j'ai doublé et j'ai pas doublé
mon chiffre d'affaires et je fais pas
plus de baguettes voilà on comprend pas
mais bon on est bien obligé alors eux
évidemment il se sert sur le compte
dernier prélèvement 7600 euros waouh ça
m'a mis à plat et là j'ai reçu ma
facture pour le 9 janvier
4495 euros voilà et je fabrique 150
baguettes par jour beaucoup de gros
pains voilà donc comment on fait comment
on fait quand on vit aussi
l'augmentation des matières premières
parce que là aussi c'est énorme et ben
moi j'ai été obligé de prévenir mon
boulanger là juste avant les fêtes non
pas mon boulanger pardon mon pâtissier
que vu la rentabilité de la pâtisserie
parce que quand vous avez payé des
salaires et les matières premières et
ben c'est plus rentable je suis obligé
de licencier deux personnes c'est à dire
me séparer de mon chef pâtissier et de
mon apprenti bâtisseur
voilà c'est c'est pas une partie de
plaisir d'annoncer ça non c'est pas du
tout une partie de plaisir on va on va
revenir sur vous Sylvie dans un instant
juste on a Dominique abrac qui était
avec nous vous êtes entretenu avec
Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui vous étiez
présent lors de cette traditionnelle
cérémonie de la galette des rois
cette cérémonie donc c'est
il vous a parlé du problème du boulanger
comme on l'a vu qu'est-ce qui vous a dit
alors bon déjà ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que cette cérémonie où on va voir
le président de la République c'est
qu'on emmène des jeunes qui ont tous
gagné des concours ou qui se sont
brillamment mis en valeur en les
meilleur apprentis de France ses
meilleurs jeunes boulangers etc donc on
emmène ces jeunes là avec la galette
pour souhaiter les vœux au président de
la République donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui pour les jeunes
marques beaucoup alors quand on est
arrivé là-bas il y a eu une annonce qui
était faite puisque sur mon discours je
lui fais part des difficultés qu'on
pouvait trouver dans la boulangerie et
donc ce qui est de nouveau parce qu'il y
a quand même beaucoup de on est quand
même sur le sujet depuis le mois de
juillet avec le ministère de l'Économie
avec Bruno Bruno Le Maire et Olivia
Grégoire et on essaie de trouver des
solutions c'est-à-dire en échange des
bilan des comptes de résultats des des
cas comme celui de par exemple Harry etc
donc alors après Sylvie c'est pareil
c'est un autre cas encore mais là on a
pu faire on avançait sur des boucliers
enfin pas des boucliers à bouclier
tarifaires qui intervient pour 20% à peu
près des boulangers là c'est moins de 36
kg le premier réglet c'est 15%
d'augmentation après il y a tous ces
compteurs jaunes qui sont compliqués
donc là comme tu disais très justement
c'est on a des des disparités dans les
dans les comment dire dans les factures
d'électricité tiens il y en a un qui ça
va être x 2 l'autre fois trois on a vu
un boulanger la CAF x 12 si ils
interviennent pas ils ferment en un mois
c'est mort tout de suite donc si la
ville c'est extrêmement compliqué selon
les dates anniversaire
il peut y avoir des des trucs qui
comment dirais-je des des factures qui
donc là ce qu'on a eu aujourd'hui bon on
a eu des choses déjà qui étaient en
route il y a du show avec le maire sur
lequel on peut déjà flinguer ces contra
toxiques c'est-à-dire ce jeune qui a eu
d'un seul coup fois 12 et ça on peut les
fusiller et là ce qu'on a eu aujourd'hui
avec lui qui ont déjà fermé d'ailleurs
voilà
donc ça je veux dire x 12 c'est bon
comment
mais comment peut-on arriver avoir une
facture de d'énergie de charge multiplié
par 12 expliquez-moi je suis pas très
intelligent j'ai pas compris moi je suis
pas le roi de vous avez je comprends pas
mais je vais vous dire comment s'est
passé ce jeune avait il a signé un
contrat sur deux ans voilà ils ont dit
qu'on trade 2 ans 1000 euros par mois
peut-être que tu avais Sylvie et puis
ils ont dit dans deux ans vous serez au
prix du marché donc le gars il y a 2 ans
ou quoi marcher ça suit il pouvait pas
personne pouvait savoir
ce qu'on non mais ce qu'on prépare là
qui savait très bien ce qui allait se
passer vous savez toutes les opérations
depuis 50 ans avec les escrocs au niveau
pognon il savait très bien ce qu'il
faisait ils mettent 5 ans 10 ans à y
arriver et ils sont fait avoir c'est pas
le premier exemple en tout cas le gars
au bout de deux ans il est arrivé
l'électricité 570 x 12 mais vous avez
toutes les aides mais vous avez tout à
fait raison sauf que vous avez aussi un
phénomène qui nous a tous touché en 2008
c'était les subprimes c'est-à-dire que
les bombes banquiers qui vous donner des
conseils disaient ne fait pas des choses
flottantes taux fixe aujourd'hui vous
faites quelque chose en disant à
quelqu'un que tu verras dans demain dans
deux ans ça sera le marché vous êtes sûr
qu'il y a une arnaque quelque part
l'arnaque on aimerait savoir Dominique
ce que vous a dit le président et les
mesures qui ont été prises pour voir si
voilà qu'on viendrait
il faut quand même commencer par ça
c'est à dire alors il a annoncé de
nouveau c'est qu'en fait les tous les
contrats pour être pourront être je
dirais on pourra les quitter tout de
suite sans indemnité et ça c'est quelque
chose que j'ai demandé à 3 jours au
ministère de l'Économie j'ai dit écoutez
la première des choses déjà c'est qu'on
puisse partir parce qu'avant il y en a
ils voulaient partir c'était il fallait
payer 60 années maintenant il voulait
repartir parce qu'ils veulent au
contraire ils vous disent de c'est ça
lui dérange pas
pendant les gros aujourd'hui
il y aura pas d'indemnités et surtout ce
qui est intéressant c'est que
l'électricité baisse maintenant donc
parce que là à l'époque où c'était vous
pouviez supprimer un contrat à 500 € le
mégawatt mais pour en trouver un 700
c'est pas très intéressant donc là le
fait d'avoir des trucs comme x 12 etc on
pourra quitter et peut-être que Sylvie
si tu as eu deux fois tu pourrais
quitter ton contrat alors moi c'est ce
que j'ai entendu mais bon là annoncé
publiquement à mon avis c'est compliqué
ça nulle
c'est à dire qu'on a déjà un guichet
unique non et si par exemple
une augmentation que vous n'êtes pas
content de votre votre contrat vous
revenez avec quelque chose qui est
plafonné dans les 220 trucs comme ça
qu’après vous avez guichet unique et
l'amortisseur là on est quand même dans
des augmentations là aujourd'hui tout le
monde va augmenter le particulier ok bon
je dis pas que c'est bien mais
visiblement on voit autour tout augmente
notamment les matières premières quand
on a parlé si ça reste dans des dans des
proportions raisonnables on augmente nos
produits 5%, on arrivera à faire face
après là où c'est par exemple des fois 6
fois 12 là vous avez beau augmenté vous
ferez pas face et après les gens
voudront plus de votre pain un tel prix
juste il y aura plus de boulanger du
tout quels sont les quels sont quels
sont les autres mesures
il y a eu ça et le fait du plafonnement
c'est quoi alors ça en fait
on a mangé la tarte alors ah ben on va
manger la galette
alors on est allé pour ça j'ai pas eu le
temps mais alors donc c'est quoi le
plafonnement pour expliquer alors le
plafonnement c'est dès le moment où on
enfin je sais pas ça s'appelle comme ça
puisque on est je dis je suis pas un
spécialiste de l'électricité mais ce
qu'on a bien vu c'est qu'on pouvait
quitter un contrat et ça c'est
primordial et aussi que dès le moment où
vous alliez dans chez un énergéticien
pour changer il y aura un prix maximum
qui est de je suis pas sûr je peux pas
le chiffre mais quelque chose de
beaucoup plus raisonnable mais c'est à
dire parce que hier on exprimait les les
tarifs les tarifs que EDF vendent par
obligation les 25% à 45
le gros le gros qui se balade le prix de
gros marché européen qui se balade entre
75 et 185 et il y a des ventes qui se
font 300 400 500 600
omégawatt il y a un moment quand on
posait la question hier qui se gavent
mais c'est des voyous je répète ce que
j'ai dit hier ça aurait jamais dû être
cette situation là c'est tout oublier
une situation commerciale puisque j'ai
j'ai assisté avec quelques énergéticiens
le problème c'est qu'un moment donné
excusez-moi qu'est-ce que vous
définissez comme énergéticien vous en
avez deux vous avez des producteurs
c'est ça bon les producteurs
si vous voulez on est dans un système on
l'a pour le beurre on l'a pour le blé il
y a l'offre et la demande et qui fait
fluctuer les prix c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui non plus bien sûr
rentre dans un marché comme ça ce qui
fait qu'un un courtier va par exemple
acheter de l'électricité pour son client
il l'achète à 500 euros par exemple le
mégawatt et bien le gars il est tenu de
le vendre à ce prix là parce que après
si descend son prix c'est lui qui perd
de l'argent d'ailleurs dans les je
défends pas les énergies énergéticiens
mais je sais que le système fonctionnait
comme ça
le président l'a vu il était en colère
il a tapé d'ailleurs sur les profits les
super profits des fondateurs d'énergie
ça c'est très bien il a critiqué le
numéro ouvert mais concrètement vous
avez l'air de vous réjouir mais
concrètement vous n'avez rien obtenu de
nouveau par rapport à ce qui allait être
fait qu'est-ce que concrètement le
Président vous a donné rien alors
concrètement rien alors moi je ne
défends pas le Président je suis pas de
politique
je suis président d'organisation
professionnelle c'est-à-dire que nous la
politique la religion n'y touche pas on
s'occupe des boulangers là qu'est-ce
qu'on a eu aujourd'hui je vous l'ai dit
le plafond que vous pouvez partir du
contrat ce qui n'était pas le cas avant
et déjà contrat de deux ans non non vous
aviez pas avant mais non monsieur vous
l'aviez pas moi je vous montre pas
Sylvie ça va pas changer sa vie monsieur
ça va pas changer sa vie du tout ce qui
a été annoncé
les boulangers
de 10000 €, je fais comment moi j'ai une
toute petite maison je suis tout seul
et Sylvie non non il faut que tu écoutes
il y a quand même un guichet unique qui
a été mis en place septembre octobre
novembre décembre ok je sais pas
j'écoute hein
on a vu au ministère on a fait le compte
il a été mis en place 50 demandes
chaque jour
on y dort non mais je sais non mais très
bien on a aussi des on va nous aider on
va je sais que c'est un drame là-dessus
au niveau de l'amortisseur qui sera mis
directement sur la rentrée ça c'est
important parce qu'ils le font pas
maintenant le guichet unique on a envoyé
un mot une experte comptable pour qui
s'occupe des clients de remplir ce
guichet et pas fait incompréhensible
de remplir se renseigner quand même
parce que voilà alors il est question de
40% de réduction sur le DF la belle
affaire hein si moi on me demande 210000
euros l'année prochaine d'électricité
40% mais ça représente quoi de 110
millions
quelques mois je vous ai vu à la
télévision vous étiez en train de dire
oui moi je paye 4000 euros d'électricité
par mois si X ça fera 40 000 en s'en
sortira pas
voilà donc on en est tous au même point
aujourd'hui moi je lis quoi qu'est-ce
qu'on me donne comme information alors
oui on peut changer de voilà mais alors
le temps que ça se fasse parce que
excusez-moi si c'est comme le numéro de
téléphone le numéro vert que tout le
monde appelle les personnes répond on se
retrouve toujours dans la même situation
pardon non mais franchement
40%, le guichet unique donc on va devoir
notre électricité en janvier en février
après ça on va faire une une un calcul
par rapport à la N-1 et on aura des
déductions donc qui va s'additionner aux
40% en fin de compte en tout on aura 40
%. si les calculs sont bons enfin c'est
rien d'y comprendre moi je peux pas
attendre jusqu'au mois de mars moi je
peux pas je suis en train de licencier
des personnel
suivi là les mesures là que nous
ramènent Dominique pour vous c'est quoi
ça va vous sauver ou pas du tout non
mais non mais moi ça va pas me sauver et
encore
tu me ruses parce que je suis dans le
centre de Paris qu'on a des touristes à
côté du lycée turbo non je suis au bout
de la rue Montorgueil en face
souterrainage
du souterrain des Halles parce que si
non parce que là c'est pas le sujet mais
franchement
merci Madame c'est l'insalubrité on est
en train de lutter contre les rats
contre les souris par le monde une
fortune
on envoie des photos la mairie de Paris
personne ne répond ça fait un mois qu'il
y a un tas énorme les ragrouilles les
sacs sont ils vont entrer moi je suis en
face la boulangerie ok comment je fais
pour lutter et contre tous ces rats
par hors dentier on les voit vous et moi
mais oui mais hors de dorats qui sortent
du souterrain évidemment mais bien sûr
je t'ai vu sortir avec non mais
comment tu fais pour lutter pour
contrôler un dans ta boulangerie dans le
sanglier
déjà je les empêche de rentrer en même
temps que
mes savoirs
monsieur s'il vous plaît empêcher la
souris de rentrer parce que moi j'ai
peur de ses bêtes là donc bon voilà
comment on fait on paye des contrats
dératisation on achète des petites
plaquettes qui coûtent une fortune des
trucs qui colle qui coûte une fortune on
fait venir ces entrepreneurs pour
reboucher les galeries que les raforment
non mais là ça m'a coûté quand même 500
euros on fait réparer le matériel que
les rats et alors ça va c'est pas non
plus parce que je voudrais pas donner
une image à ma boulangerie on va dire
tiens celle-ci non non mais sérieusement
non mais sérieusement on en a marre je
suis allé voir tous les commerçants du
quartier tous les restaurateurs mais je
leur ai dit mais qu'est-ce que vous
faites là il se passe rien moi je sors
d'un cancer là parce que le stress ça me
voilà j'ai même pas repris le travail je
suis allé l'élevant j'ai dit mais c'est
quoi ce taboubelle c'est ils m'ont dit
on fait des photos personne ne bouge
mais il faut il faut il faut vraiment
qu'on se mobilise bien sûr on peut pas
vivre dans la plus belle ville du monde
à accueillir des touristes
on appelle la poubelle vide du monde
voilà non mais c'est vraiment ça Hidalgo
on change un peu de sujet c'est vrai
au quotidien et certainement pas toi
Dominique dans le 16e Dominique est-ce
que aussi j'habite à côté euh j'en ai vu
je suis en tout cas les halles à côté
ici juste Dominique est-ce que les
boulangers vont s'en sortir ou pas oui
alors il faut quand même essayer d'être
un petit peu positif alors Sylvie la
elle est dans un quartier parisien a une
covid tu as oublié les grèves
les gilets jaunes à la ça la dérouillé
mais
ça recommence donc ma galette je fais
quoi
à mon avis des gilets vont changer de
couleur
sur le dossier des boulangers moi je
vous dis qu'ils vont passer la crise ça
va pas être simple ça sera pas la
meilleure année où ils vont travailler
il y a des aides il y a des gens moi je
m'occupe des boulangers
il est trop tard tu parleras demain mon
chéri
il y a plusieurs solutions c'est à dire
enfin des solutions c'est une valse à
quatre temps c'est à dire que le les
boulangers des choses augmentent il faut
qu'ils augmentent un peu leur pain et ça
c'est très compliqué regardez même je
demande à l'époque moi mon flan quand je
casse des œufs ma boîte ma caisse d'oeuf
elle a doublé de prix non attends
quand même 30 %
grosso modo moi je dirais déjà à la base
avec l'électricité matière première
minimum 5%.
non on va on va en parler on va voir les
consommateurs ils ont pas les moyens les
chéris on est en retard vous êtes dans
une entreprise allez on vous avez des
contacts vous avez des charges variables
on en reparle il faut augmenter
merci merci